what's up believe nation today I'm going
to talk about the seven reasons why
Millennials should start their business
today so I get a lot of messages
comments emails from Millennials young
people who are trying to start a
business they want to do it with drugs
sure should i start up now should i wait
and so here is my advice on the several
reasons why you should be starting a
business right now today reason number
one is you have no responsibility i
remember when i was in university I was
in my commerce class we had a guest be
to come in and he said you guys need to
start today whatever whatever thing you
want to do whatever passion you have do
it right now don't wait because when you
get older you have a lot of
responsibilities and it's going to be
harder to to get started and I thought
yeah but I have a lot of
responsibilities now man like you don't
know what you're talking about I got a
lot happening I got a lot of people that
I need to make sure i'm spending time
with I have a lot of responsibilities
and I shouldn't have disrespected that
advice because it's true as you get
older when you have to think about you
have a spouse you have kids you have
mortgage you have all the parents might
have to be looking after there's a lot
more weight that you have on your life
until the time to explore is now when
you're younger that's the time to make
bigger mistakes that's the time to
really go out and chase what you want to
do and see if it works or not to
discover yourself because once you get
on a corporate path that's what you do
you'll get a job it's really hard to
leave at the beginning it's easy to
leave because you're not making much
money you haven't taken on a mortgage
you don't have a lot of responsibilities
as you get older as you move your way up
it's hard to leave that high so go do
something new and scary and different
one because you've done it for so long
you just want to keep doing it because
that's the habit you've built up and two
you're making more money and while
you've made more money you've gone out
and bought that house and have kids to
pay for and a spouse to pay for and not
having that reliable steady income
stream makes it
really really difficult to jump off it's
not impossible still absolutely doable
just makes it hard and so why make life
harder for yourself if you don't have to
start now when you don't have a kind of
responsibility number two is you can
offer immediate value young people are
respected now in a way that they've
never been respected in the past it used
to be for any career for any job or any
you know entren your way up you had to
learn the business you have to get
experience you had to understand how
things work and the older you got the
more experience you built up and that
allows you to offer the more value and
yes it's true that experience helps
allow you to bring more value to your
customers but young people are looked at
now with way more respect than they used
to be because you guys have skills that
older people don't have if you're
looking about the importance of
technology and the importance of social
media and how quickly things are
changing for older people who aren't
using social media they don't understand
how to market on snapchat and YouTube
and Instagram you're using it daily you
grew up with it and so they're looking
to you to help them understand their
strategy and figure it out you know most
people aren't going to hire a 75 year
old to help them manage their snapchat
account because most 75 year olds didn't
grow up using snapchat they're going to
hire the 75 year old for something else
or leadership or strategy for all the
other things with skill such as a build
up of their life experience but for
things like social media and technology
and emerging trends you guys grew up
with it and so there's a lot more
respect you can offer immediate value
people are looking to young people as
thought leaders are ready in a way that
hasn't happened as much in the past so
this is your chance to offer media value
and make some money and build a business
[Music]
number three is you don't need money you
don't need money to start a business
anymore you don't need to have a company
car and an office and you know expensive
equipment you're not building anything
as much anymore right you don't need
money to start a business and maybe part
of your goal you may long-term want to
be a manufacturing may long-term one
have an office and have a team and have
staff and that's great it's great to
have that big-picture vision for what
you want to go but to start now you
don't need money you'll need a retail
location you could start off with a
website that you really need to design
because you can start off with a
Facebook page right all you need is this
you have this you can start a business
and it's going to be about your energy
your heart your hustle your ability to
deliver results the ability to talk to
people and get them excited about your
vision what you're trying to do you can
offer immediate value without having to
spend any money it's never been easier
it's ever cost less we started with this
and so you don't have the excuses that
used to be able to have in the past why
you can't start right number four is
there's an abundance of role model if
you see somebody who's like you who's
run out and done something that you want
to do it means you can do it too yes you
could try to be the exception if you try
to be the first whatever try to do it
there was risk associated with that you
may not hit that mark you may not be the
first one in still you want to take that
courageous step amazing but if somebody
has already done it then it means it's
possible it's doable we made a video way
back one of our first reduce to pop was
about breaking the four-minute mile to
be able to run a mile in under four
minutes what seemed to be impossible and
then one guy did it and then after that
lots of people have done it high
schoolers have done it because they knew
it was possible for anyone who did it
themselves there's tons of people who
are younger than you who have started a
business and had massive success there's
never been such an abundance of role
models to look to if they can do it and
have success at a young age you can too
with nothing holding you back
[Music]
number five is they're insanely good
resource I'm old enough to remember in
high school and in grade school going to
library right I went to my school
library to find resources and then in
high school it was about encyclopedias
and it was on cd-rom the university was
internet and a lot of information I can
get from there I remember going to my
university class and taking a course on
entrepreneurship and it was so basic and
so boring I was already running my
company I learned almost nothing I can't
remember one thing that I learned in my
fourth year you know level university
class and entrepreneurship and that sort
of time where there wasn't a lot of
content out there right look at how much
information there is now look at how
many just in the YouTube world alone how
many people are creating content to help
entrepreneurs what do you like my videos
whether you like Gary these videos Louis
houses videos there's lots of people who
are creating great content to help you
that you have such an abundance of
information around you that never
existed before you don't have to rely on
having a parent teaching something you
don't have to rely on having a decent
high school teacher or university and
feature review the Keen the teas are
everywhere there's tons of people need
to learn from you've done what you want
to do it's never been easier to model
their success and so whatever goal you
have somebody figured it out and it made
a video about it or they've done a
podcast about it they've written an
e-book about it pick those things up and
learn it's never been easier number six
is accesses never been easier if you
want to reach out to somebody and get
their opinion how to look your business
plan or give you some mentoring or
coaching advice it's never been easier
to reach people you know ten years ago
if you wanted to reach an entrepreneur
how would you do it some some big
entrepreneur how would you reach out to
them you have to go maybe actually knock
on their companies or and go through
eight levels of gatekeepers and maybe
get that meeting or hopefully find them
at some event or trade show and be one
of the people in the honest and maybe
get their attention
it's never been easier now people are
all on Twitter there on social media you
can reach out now you still have to
provide value don't assume that
everybody that you reach out to say hey
can you give me help that they're going
to respond there's still a barrier and
the barrier is proving to that person
that you're worth spending time on
because a lot of people reach out to
people as potential mentors and they
never actually do the work and so the
mentors now don't want to help people
because they're afraid that you're going
to be another person who doesn't do the
work so you need to provide value to
stand out but it's never been easier go
to Twitter find the person engage with
their stuff are they tweeting are they
sharing can you retweet them can you
support them can you give them a piss
advice whenever you're trying to
accomplish complain finding somebody
who's already done it and asking for
some help whether it's a coffee meeting
whether it's you know foots phone call
if you've built up enough value there
are people in this channel y know we've
never met in person but they comment on
all the videos they share they tweaked
the videos oh they add as much as you
can to the believe nation community if
they needed me for something that they
wanted me to check out their business
plan if they want to hop on a quick
phone call to talk about something I
would say yes because they've added so
much value ten years ago it wasn't
possible was it possible to reach out to
that person and get that connection and
understand that people have had success
for the most part want to give back as
well because somewhere along the line
somebody help them right for me mentors
helped me get to where I'm at and so I
want to help other people it's really
fulfilling to give back and help but
again making sure that it's the people
who are actually going to do the work
and so separating yourself out as being
the hustler of being a person will grind
it will take you price a little bit of
advice and just go and push hard on it
and achieve some success and then come
back after a little bit more advice it's
really important but the access has
never been easier to get on somebody's
radar you can give you meaningful advice
in a conversation
[Music]
and number seven is good both you don't
have to do one or the oven you don't
have to have a career or start a
business you could do both in parallel
and I actually recommend it I think if
your long-term goal is to be an
entrepreneur and have your own business
then go work for an entrepreneur don't
go work at some big bank go work for an
entrepreneur who is a little bit ahead
of you who has 10 employees you could
see yourself being in three to five
years go work for them and take them as
much as you can to learn not just your
one specific role but get close to the
entrepreneur founder learn as much as
you can understanding industry
understand how their business works
you're essentially getting paid to go to
school right right now you're paying to
go to school you're getting paid now to
learn how an industry works and at the
same time you start your business you
start your side hustle you're off
grinding trying to make this thing work
and everything you learn from your job
you're now applying to your business
that's why it's so important to get a
job where you're going to learn if you
get paid but you're going to learn
because it makes you a better
entrepreneur make you better human being
and the thing is you're going to learn
over here you're going to bring to your
business you're going to start to build
it up and when you get to the point
where either you're not learning as much
as you used to at that job you had or
where your own business is getting to
the point where it's sustaining you you
can afford to quit the job then you can
go all in on your business I wouldn't
approach any situation where it's either
one or the other often the answer to
those should i do this or should i do
this often the answer is yes you both in
great the DSBN children of my seven
reasons why millennials should start
their business today I love to know what
do you guys think what was your favorite
rule what residents most with you then I
miss some is there an eight nine ten
that you guys want to add to the list
let me know leave it down the comments
below I'm going to join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to 109 innovations thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying it thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon